don't be fooled by the big mouth basking
sharks sluggish demeanor while it spends
most of its time slowly slurping its way
through plankton filled waters every
once in a while this mammoth fish the
second largest in the sea hurls its body
entirely out of the water a team of
international scientists use video
analysis and a data logger to measure
the vertical velocity of basking shark
breaches off the coast of Ireland in
this video the researchers have equipped
a male basking shark with an accelerator
in just 10 beats of its tail or nine
seconds the fish propels itself from a
depth of 28 meters to the water surface
a miracle in the study they clocked some
of the animal speeds at up to five
meters per second just a scooch faster
than their great white shark cousins and
these jumps are energetically costly for
the plankton eaters scientists estimate
that a single breach cost the basking
shark 50% more of their daily caloric
intake than great whites of a similar
size it's thought that great white
sharks breach to snatch meals lingering
near the ocean surface why filtered
feeding sharks exhibit this behavior is
not known basking sharks might be trying
to rid themselves of parasites ward off
predators or perhaps court mates in
nearby waters but regardless of the
reason researchers believe these new
data should shift our perspective on
other supposedly slow-going creatures
[Music]